además de las evidentes discrepancias
entre las potencias que otras
conclusiones se pueden sacar de este
encuentro en qué sentido se
comprometieron a cooperar bueno yo creo
que lo más interesante es el lugar
elegido por los eeuu ya fue una señal
los movimientos previos de washington en
digamos previo esta cumbre gira por
japón corea del sur reunión del cual que
integran además de estos dos países
australia y la india con fuertes
mensajes anti china ya daba la pauta de
lo que podríamos esperar y luego la
disposición no de las mesas no fue una
mesa de negociación había cómodo suerte
de tribunas en los cuales cada parte
dijo lo que tenía que decir en términos
durísimos e inusuales en términos de
incluso lo que fue la época de tram no
las negociaciones entre sí en eeuu a la
época de trump vimos una rispidez en
este caso inusitada y creo que fue más
bien como una suerte de demostración de
los eeuu de que no está dispuesto a dar
marcha atrás como muchos esperaban por
ejemplo una cuestión comercial en la
cuestión tecnológica
además poniendo con fuerza otros temas
muy complejos como la cuestión de los
derechos humanos que para bailén en
particular es muy importante por eso de
ahora en más creo que podemos esperar un
sendero de más confrontación más bien
que de negociaciones justo estas lo
mencionaba uno de los principales temas
de confrontación entre ambas naciones es
el comercio hay alguna forma en que
ambos países trabajen en conjunto en
este ámbito bueno yo siempre he dicho
que es la parte más sencilla de resolver
de este conflicto porque estamos
hablando de que el epicentro es un gran
déficit comercial que china tiene en
favor de los estados unidos y que
beijing
continuamente ha dicho que está
dispuesto a vender más digamos mejor
dicho a comprar más desde los eeuu se
llegó un acuerdo de fase 1 en enero del
2020 que está congelado yo creo que lo
comercial es lo más sencillo lo más
complicado es el verdadero trasfondo de
esta disputa que es china convirtiéndose
en una superpotencia tecnológica que le
disputa de igual a igual a eeuu en una
serie de campos estratégicos ahí yo creo
que
al igual que pasó en la época de trump
vader no va a retroceder en eso
y repito la cuestión de los derechos
humanos esta acusación de ciberataques
echarle limpiamos cara a cara esto ha
sido muy duro también y va a complicar
mucho las relaciones pero lo comercial
puede llegar a avanzar por otros
carriles mucho más amistoso digamos
retomo justamente lo que acaba de decir
sobre los derechos humanos porque fue
otro de los focos de la cumbre eeuu
señala puntualmente situación en
xinjiang en el tíbet en hong kong y
china dice que washington tiene
problemas de derechos humanos que no
aborda cómo se puede conciliar en un
aspecto tan polémico bueno que yo creo
que en esto no va a haber mucho mucho
espacio para conciliar hay un gran
acuerdo bipartidario en los estados
unidos cuando trump digamos promovió
sanciones a oficiales chinos por la
cuestión de los derechos humanos en
shinchan en el tíbet y también en hong
kong los demócratas aprobaron apoyaron
digamos con unanimidad todo eso así que
en eso no haber un retroceso y vemos en
eeuu mucho más débil como bien lo marco
china en la reunión
les han tomado el capítulo ustedes están
teniendo grandes problemas de abuso
policial con lo cual quiénes son ustedes
ahora para alzar la voz en materia
derechos humanos chinas se siente más
fuerte y los eeuu está en una posición
mucho más débil en términos relativos
así que yo creo que en este campo y
repito para los demócratas es un tema
central de la gente en este campo no va
a haber muchos avances lamentablemente